Verizon really is committed to honoring
first responders and that emotional spot
was connected to a documentary executive
produced by Hollywood director Peter
Berg et teamed up with Verizon to bring
you an inside look at the team that
wouldn't be here
they're all great stories it's hard to
not be moved by you know young people
that show up and rush into harm's way
and save a life I'm simple cars 150
miles an hour and I promise y'all would
be Earth Day if it wasn't for the first
responders the team that wouldn't be
here highlights the emotional stories of
one coach in 11 NFL players who owed
their lives to these unsung heroes we
were with them at the premiere of the
documentary that airs tonight on CBS
Sports for me the coach Lynn storms
particularly emotional and to meet the
young police officer who's first to find
him on the ground
who literally put his hands inside of
his body there's open wounds to hold the
bleeding Lykos my name is Jim brittle
it's my partner Craig Kelly were the
first two first responders on the scene
what does it mean to be here now oh
these first responders my life I want to
get these guys all the recognition that
they deserve the only thing I remember
is us hitting the buoy losing control
not hit the pier face-first
I've always been super thankful for chip
being there that day I'm just super
thankful for all our heroes you know
Verizon really is committed to showing
support for first responders so for
every social share that includes the
hashtag all our thanks now through
Friday Verizon will donate $1 to the
first responders outreach up to 1.5
million dollars